am montag wird am red bull ring in
zeltweg im zuge einer pressekonferenz
der termin der nächsten airpower bekannt
gegeben den zweiten und dritten
september
2022 sollten sich eher power fans im
kalender rot anstreichen dabei wird es
ein programm am boden geben in der luft
geben es werden 200 zivil und militär
luftfahrzeuge aus rund 20 nationen ihr
können zeigen besonderes augenmerk wird
bei dieser airpower auf die
umweltverträglichkeit insgesamt gelegt
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
betont dass er power flugstunden keinen
zusätzlichen flugbetrieb darstellen für
unser als bundesheer als
verteidigungsressort die airpower ihr
habt noch viel mehr als nur eine
veranstaltung in wahrheit ist es auch
eine militärische großübung und als
solche ist sie auch zu sehen was die
eingesetzten flugzeuge selbst anbetrifft
so ist auch wichtig eines festzuhalten
dass im rahmen des freigegebenen
flugstunden kontingents die airpower
durchgeführt wird das heißt es werden
dann im jahr 2022 keine zusätzlichen
flugstunden absolviert die zehnte er
in der steiermark anfang september
2022 ist also fix ebenso fix der
eintritt ist wie immer frei